well let's jump and talk to uh let's
talk about UFOs man we got the story
from timcast.com White House Press
Secretary addresses concerns about UFOs
says there is no indication of aliens
but she didn't say it wasn't aliens
which means it could be we all keep our
fingers crossed or not because every
every movie we've ever watched about
aliens typically ends very poorly for
humans or I should say ends up in War I
mean maybe we win or something
it's not Independence Day I don't think
yeah
very concerned very concerned of
interstellar traveling beings showed up
here and wanted to fight yeah that would
be why though why would that be uh if
they wanted to fight yeah
I don't think that we have the
technology to withstand yeah right we
just get wiped out yeah so so but I
would like I would like to live oh no
right I thought you were saying you'd be
surprised if they did want to fight no
no no I would I wouldn't be uh I don't
think did I say surprise I think I'd be
scared yeah oh yeah yeah so uh uh says
there is no indication the UFOs that
have entered American airspace are
aliens I know there have been questions
and concerns about this but there is no
again no indication of aliens or
extraterrestrial activity with these
recent takedowns I wanted to make sure
that the American people knew that all
of you knew that and it was important
for us to say that from here because
we've been hearing a lot about it I love
ET the movie but I'm just going to leave
it there so apparently they shot down
three objects
they don't know what they are and they
don't know how they fly and the the F-22
pilot said there was no visible
propulsion system on these on these
objects which I'm like I hate to break
the news everybody who's hoping it's
aliens it could just be like a quad like
a drone but it's got small Jets or
something like there's a million ways to
explain how this thing's flying that's
not anti-gravity or aliens you know what
I mean I don't expect to be uh any kind
of extraterrestrials
um I am extremely interested to find out
what it is because I imagine that if the
government was if it was you like
American I imagine the government
wouldn't want to shoot it down so that
right there you know perks my interest
about the topic I like that Paul gosar
responds with his own uh the real alien
invasion is the 6 million illegal aliens
are crossing the border and the
government won't talk about that I mean
I feel like she answered this question
because she doesn't want to talk about
Ohio she doesn't want to talk about a
lot of stuff and so she'll give out this
funny oh I I like the movie ET too just
to sort of act like she's one of the
people I mean uh pazaki was at least
somewhat on good terms I mean people
didn't like her but she had a rapport
with the journalist in the room I don't
think that uh Jean-Pierre has the same
sort of Charisma that her predecessor
did yo look when you had
um under Trump you had say uh Kaylee
mcinerney she opens the book and pulls
up the news article and then refutes the
lies from the Press yeah when you get
the Democrats in they don't have any
sources or information they just lie to
you in very obvious ways yeah trust me
bro so maybe it was great but so that
what I'm saying here is this proves it's
aliens
I kind of wish
I really you know like they're coming
down they're like you guys are having a
hard time
issue right just from uh just from a um
a policy standpoint if if
extraterrestrial beings showed up here
we don't know if they're aggressive and
then you just kill them
Independence Day too yeah the big sphere
shows up and they're like shoot it and
it turns out to be the alien trying to
save them from the other aliens but you
know also what if they send more you
blow that one up and they're like two
sets of aliens what two oh I didn't see
that yeah in part two a giant sphere
appears and they're like shoot it and
they blast it then it turns out that
sphere was actually good aliens I didn't
even know there was an independence day
too yeah it was not that good we mix
equals to everything yeah the the reason
nobody wanted to watch it was because
Dave Smith wasn't in it no Mae Whitman
wasn't in it oh she played the daughter
of Bill Pullman but they recast some
other woman everyone got mad because
because she's the right age to play the
character and for some reason they were
like nah we don't want Mae Whitman but
she's like Mae Whitman was in she's in a
bunch of stuff she's she's Katara in uh
Avatar so she has a lot of fans I'm
kidding by the way that's not why nobody
saw it I'm sure I'm sure the movie made
a lot of money but like people who are
fans were just like what are you doing
this is dude there's one guy who like
saw this movie and knows everything
about it and he's like so sad he just
said that yes he's like oh there's
someone who's a big fan of Avatar and
they're all like Tim's exactly right
about this they should not have recast
May Whitman 100 yep you see that proves
it all right so Independence Day two uh
so what's the worst what's the over
under on this one it could be Russian
could be Chinese we just got breaking
news earlier that uh China is flying uh
warplanes into Taiwanese airspace so
like the over under on this is they do
this it's not like a new thing it's it's
they're just pushing and pushing and
pushing it could be that China is is
increasing their surveillance Tech and
capabilities because they're getting
ready for a full-scale military conflict
so it's like why don't what we haven't
we've not seen these weird vessels these
UFOs before they're deploying them now
basically as you ever play you ever play
Warcraft
was the eye of kill Rog was that what it
was you guys in the chat can help me out
this one uh you you could so it's it's
you know what it is the game you build a
little bass on the other base you can
send a floating eye to go look around
and see what your enemy is doing before
you Tech that's what it sounds like yeah
they're sending out the the gear we
don't know what it is
spying on us stealing our data on
information maybe even injecting viruses
into our facilities because then
you know what I think is going to happen
I can be honest
if War breaks out everyone expects you
know nuclear missiles to like launch out
of the ground and fly through the air I
bet what happens is as soon as a country
declares war every other country hits
the go button on their viruses they've
installed in all the Deep infrastructure
for other countries everyone's power
just goes out instantly something like
that Factory's all shut down nuclear
plants blow up well I mean if Jesus is
so positive though I mean it's it's
actually that's probably what's going to
happen it's better than than nuclear
fire I imagine well so do you know about
stocksnet no U.S and Israel worked on a
cyber weapon that basically infected
every computer hoping that it would
eventually make its way to Iranian
nuclear centrifuges and caused them to
spin out of control and blow up
so if we know that happened you're
willing to bet China's got viruses in
U.S systems we don't know about we got
viruses in their systems
every Tick-Tock account is going to
spread to every computer and then your
phone's gonna kill you look anything you
know hello anybody that has a Cisco
router they might be able to blow your
phone up remotely yeah possibly cause
like an energy drain or something cause
it to overheat who knows I don't know oh
I hope not those Lithium-ion batteries
man they get exposed to oxygen they go
up yeah that's why I'll remember when
all those phones were blown up and like
cases with charging things they banned
them from Planes yeah because of that
yeah yeah because those Lithium-ion
batteries mats expose that to air rapid
oxidization and I never understood what
you did like if you had the Samsung
phone you weren't allowed to complain if
you get to your gate you just like turn
it over and they mail it to you I don't
know there was somebody who named their
iPhone Wi-Fi Galaxy Note 5 or whatever
and then turned it on I guess it's a
joke then when people saw the Wi-Fi with
the name they shut the plane down and
they're like nope we're not flying until
we get this plane off all right we get
that phone off the plane
crazy right it's a crazy world we live
in it's such a great joke no I I think
you know uh War Maybe
I I I think that award him a World War I
think that I think it's I think that if
China is
is likely to make a move I think that
now is is a time where they would be
likely to do it because the U.S is not
in a position look China said to the U.S
the first time that that uh Lincoln met
with his uh his Chinese uh um whatever
the the equivalent real real quick um
just this is a breaking news in the past
about 15 minutes there's an active
shooter at MSU near Berkeley Hall
Michigan State University Police have
asked students to secure in place
immediately following shots being fired
police are active on the scene so uh if
that affects any of you just wanted to
make sure I know that because we're
getting people in the chat mentioning
anyway sorry to interrupt me and I
thought that was important if anybody
was nearby I needed to hear that well
that is that is important if you're at
the uh I'm looking at it now Michigan
State University yeah yeah so yep yep
yep but uh you don't have to if you're
there world war three is not your
immediate concern yeah for the rest of
us the toxic chemical spill comes first
yeah and then um wokeness I guess
because that's the order we told the
story
China is fairly ongoing the tensions
have been high over over Taiwan for you
know yeah a while now yeah but I don't
know maybe this is it maybe maybe like
they know that we're trapped in Ukraine
and if they're gonna move they gotta
move now like I said earlier they they
they had told Lincoln that the US is not
they do not believe the US is
negotiating from a position of strength
and this is the way that China behaves
when they don't believe that the US is
in a position of strength they are going
to push they're going to prod and
they're going to see if it makes sense
for them to take Taiwan because they
intend to take Taiwan back this is not
an option to them it's just a matter of
when so yeah I think China is such an
interesting adversary I wrote the story
today about how the US issued a don't
travel and if you're in Russia come home
immediately alert but also said
we can't offer we can't guarantee that
we're able to offer you try transport
home so figure it out immediately and
also get back but the kremlin's response
was like meh they've issued these alerts
before I mean the US says this kind of
thing I can't imagine what the
conversation China is having with its
own people about the way we react to the
balloons you know like we didn't shoot
one down I can't imagine that China
would not have taken this kind of action
if someone else floated a balloon across
their country uh it seems like I think
we're on with Jack fasovic who said uh
they're doing this to see how we react
and I personally and I think the
Senators and from Montana agree with me
I think reacted too slowly I don't
remember his name on top of my head but
one of the federal officials from
Montana said we we
uh we took care of the balloon a
continent too late we knew about it
before it reached U.S airspace we saw it
coming and we didn't do anything and
that's a pretty powerful message not to
just not only just under people but to
your adversaries right we couldn't get
it together this is funny Vice has an
article that says the conspiracy verse
thinks fake UFOs are a distraction from
a disastrous train derailment accidental
environmental activism from a surprising
Source it just goes to show that these
people really do not understand anything
about the people they insult and smear
every day you know like the government
lied about the quality of air on 9 11.
they're probably lying now about what's
going on in Ohio like but you're a
conspiracy theorist you shouldn't care
about the environment it's like okay you
have you just you've lost you're lost in
the cult yeah you live in a weird world
man I know tons of very intense
conservatives who really believe in
protecting the environment right it's
our big great resource I think the left
has this idea everyone who lives on the
planet
should care about the environment yeah
when it comes to like oil spills and
nuclear explosions chemicals or China's
massive plastic island in the in
the in the ocean from their fishing nets
you're right but in addition to that
like like to Hannah's Point um hunters
and and outdoorsmen are tend to be
conservative
um and those people and hunting
organizations uh you know the NRA and
stuff like that they they do a lot of
work to keep natural resources in
conditions so that way you know Hunters
can go out and Hunt still like the
preservation of Natural Resources is
something that is extremely close to you
know
naturalists and hunters and and
Sportsmen and stuff like that fishermen
yeah you know that's and they do a lot
of really good work not just you know
chaining themselves to trees or or
trying to
get in the way of of
hunting and fishing your own food is
probably
the most green thing you can do yeah you
know what I mean because it's like you
know you've seen Piers Morgan ripping
apart people like
you know talking about how much actual
Destruction has caused to bees and and
Bulls and animals who you know and all
the the the wasted gas on flying
avocados and almonds all over the planet
plastic and the shipping materials all
and and the amount of biodiversity that
has to be destroyed in order to live a
vegan lifestyle and then and they don't
it doesn't equate to them right because
they see the PETA videos and the factory
farming which is not right either right
if I I go to a I go to a butcher that is
like a farmer's butcher yeah you know
what I mean and I I just actually
started switching to deer meat from from
cat from cows yeah
um because it's better for you and the
animals live in the wild and they're not
stressed out they believe I think so
many people believe in the stereotypes
that are definitely left lane culture
has created right if you're a hunter
especially if you hunt for your own food
you need to have a relationship with the
lands you can't overcome and all you
hear is but we hunted the Buffalo to
almost Extinction
the Europeans who are fighting the that
was a war tactic right that the
Europeans who were fighting with the
Native Americans killed their food
source in order to starve them out but
what they're saying is these people who
are just so out of control they just
like killing things for fun like it's
it's a complete uh misrepresentation of
what having a relationship with with
land especially if it's to feed your
family is like I think they believe
these stereotypes and can't consider
that other people also believe in
protecting the Earth thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time